there's a strong chance you have never
heard of the first person of color to
play in what would become the nba but
today we'll share the legendary story of
the late wataru wat masaka
wak masaka was born to japanese
immigrants in ogden utah and raised in
his father's barbershop basement he
experienced racism growing up including
being banned from restaurants because of
his ancestry nevertheless masaka stayed
committed to excellence in the classroom
and in sports in high school he was
captain of the football team played
baseball and basketball and ran track
the hardwood is where he would shine the
brightest and earn his nickname as the
kilowatt for his speed as an undersized
point guard he led ogden high school to
a state championship in 1940 and a
regional championship as a senior in
1941. masaka's winning ways continued in
the college ranks he helped lead weber
junior college to back-to-back
conference championships and won an ncaa
title in 1944 and an nit championship in
1947 at the university of utah to put a
bow on his collegiate career you might
be wondering about the gap between those
two titles well masaka was drafted into
the u.s army after the first and at one
point stationed in hiroshima japan after
the u.s bombed the city in 1945. masaka
told university of utah magazine
continuum i was a man without a country
to the japanese i was an invader
americans didn't trust me because i was
japanese
world war ii had a massive effect on
masaka and all those with asian heritage
living in america as the result of a
1942 executive order from u.s president
franklin d roosevelt now widely
understood as a civil and human rights
violation an estimated 120 000 people of
japanese descent were incarcerated in
desolate and remote parts of the united
states forced to live in barracks
following the events of pearl harbor
after his collegiate career the new york
knicks would select misaka in the
seventh round making him the first
non-white basketball player ever to play
in the basketball association of america
a precursor to the nba masaka told npr
in 2012 i never did think of myself as a
pioneer of any sort but masaka indeed
paved the way for so many
wat masaka
trailblazer
barrier breaker
you